well are you looking to make some extra
cash why not possibly rent out your
backyard pool when you aren't using it
yeah brian dozens of homeowners are now
taking part in a pool
sharing trend in our area during the
pandemic and they're making a profit
thanks to a website called swimply
victoria saha takes us to a backyard
pool in the southwest area that will
make you feel like you
traveled to a tropical destination
if you don't have your own swimming pool
to beat the scorching summer heat of las
vegas
look no further the website swimply lets
you dive
right into a stranger's pool for an
hourly fee with a click of a button
the concept is like renting out an
airbnb but it's only for the pool
we have the waterfalls you know it's
solar so it's
nice and warm you know families our
friends enjoy it we just great
we just make great memories out here
with our kids which is why jennifer
gonzalez signed up on swimply to let
other people make new memories in a pool
you don't come across too often
gonzales calls this her desert oasis she
tells me at first she was skeptical
before listing the pool
but now she's gotten the next couple of
weekends booked
you know i think it's a really good
concept you know if
your work during the day you can rent
your backyard out you're not there
anyway might as well make some extra
money
for 100 an hour you could enjoy
gonzalez's uniquely built pool
and her backyard but this is just one of
the dozens of backyard pools available
to rent in las vegas
the website has rates starting at ten
dollars an hour
gonzalez says a lot of her renters are
skipping the day clubs that many of the
las vegas hotels have to offer
it's expensive and then you have a crowd
of a whole bunch of people this is
you know mostly more of your family the
website started a few years ago but
quickly took
off during the pandemic with 3 thousand
listings across the country in the last
6 months in las vegas there are
currently 69 listings
victoria saha 8 news now the website
does take
15 percent of every booking for
insurance now if you want to do this if
you want to rent out your backyard pool
we have a link up to do so
on our website at 8newsnow.com